it's become an early morning ritual for
Leoben Hashanah kava for weeks now she's
been making noise on the way to work
while Bulgaria's Parliament is in
session outside the crowds anger is
growing a bunch of people who can't
understand anything can't do anything
and don't want to do anything these are
the bunch of people the new prime
minister plumbin orishan ski a socialist
governing with the aid of right-wing
extremists the demonstrators outside say
the politicians are only in it for
themselves Bulgaria is one of the most
corrupt countries in the European Union
today orizarska is presenting a new
candidate for the head of Bulgaria's
domestic intelligence agency it's the
Prime Minister's second try
On June 14th the opposition took to the
streets to protest his first candidate
the old governing party had to give in
to the pressure of the streets
now it's boycotting Parliament but the
demonstrators also blame it for
Bulgaria's problems they didn't really
do anything they just pretend to do
their job she means Boyko Borissov on
the right the former conservative Prime
Minister he's seen here talking with his
former interior minister espionage Fiat
an elf who is now under investigation
Boris OMPs conservatives long Dean
discussion partners for the EU are also
accused of corruption I can't confirm a
single case of such practices that's why
I say where we govern where we provide
the mayor's I can guarantee the day to
their work perfectly the guren theorem
the torture report is perfect
Liuba nacho likova says this is a lie
Borissov himself is accused of dirty
business and that's why she and her
husband come to demonstrate everyday
Bulgaria is the only country where the
Mafia has a state its own state and that
shows how this country is governed like
most of the demonstrators the Chola
comas are well educated middle class
people with jobs they're concerned about
the state of democracy in their country
things can't get any worse than they are
right now you Bennett agrees they can't
something has to change the protests
began without leaders six weeks ago it
was a grassroots movement and there are
plenty of activists in Bulgaria for
example gyoji Alexandrov and his wife
Anita for weeks the two teachers have
been juggling work demonstrations and
social networking we can't afford to
remain apathetic in times like these
it's reminiscent of the end of communism
in 1989 but one thing is different today
there was the casual I don't think
anyone would have held out for 36 days
on the street back then you see a
curvature Gyeonggi Alexandrov says it's
time for a new democratic revolution but
this time there's the internet and
professionals who know how to organize
protests Assange Gandalf and Konstantin
Pavlov are bloggers and took part in the
protests from the beginning
Smitham chair i think the time has come
for bulgarian society to free itself
from the burdens of the post communist
era he means by that the oligarchs and
the political mafia it's evening and
once again the Obama and Nicolae set off
it's Day 36 let's go every evening
demonstrations for a Democratic European
Bulgaria people come from all walks of
life families from every social strata
meet here in front of the Parliament
building
Niko Lonza Benna the bloggers konstantin
and ascent the teachers hornet son yogi
Aleksandrov they meet each other for the
first time today
now they meet in person artist satirize
the politicians and the demonstrations
draw evermore people until the crowds
number 10,000 again that's the slogan
every evening since June 14th
back then it was against the
Conservatives now the socialist
government against Bulgaria's whole
political class and the wheeler-dealers
behind them